everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're going to be
starting a very important series one
that I think you're going to want to
watch all the videos in the series and
it's going to be a series on chess in
game strategy and tactics we talked a
lot about opening theory and middle game
theory strategy and tactics but if you
don't have a strong endgame you're not
going to be a good chess player so I
want to take some time and make some
good videos on chess in game strategy
and tactics and today we're going to be
looking at minor pieces and minor pieces
have some similarities to the middle
game in the endgame but they also have
some key differences so today I want to
touch on the similarities that you need
to think about with your minor pieces
but also some very distinct differences
when you approach the in games how your
minor pieces are going to differ then
you would when looking at the middle
game so the first thing we want to take
a look at is the bishops and bishops as
we've talked about in other videos reign
supreme and open games if you haven't
watched the video on opening closed
positions you may want to take a look at
that but this is an open position here
and bishops do much better in open
positions they can they have a lot of
room to move around and they can reach
their fullest potential and a close game
where pawns have fixed positions in the
middle and the bishops are blocked off
the bishops really don't have as much
potential as Knights if we look at
Knights in a closed position you can see
that they can Knights can hop over
pieces so they can control the entire
board even if the pawns are fixed in the
middle where the bishops if you can
imagine the bishops can't move anywhere
if the middle of the board is fixed with
pawns now these are some key
similarities between the middle and
endgame bishops are going to reign
supreme in open games and Knights are
going to reign supreme in close games
another similarity in the middle and
endgame
is that two nights really don't work as
well together as two bishops two nights
really control the same squares they do
the same thing and two nights together
not nearly as powerful as two bishops
two bishops although they move the same
they control different color squares so
if you have a LightSquared bishop in a
dark square but if they can control the
entire board fairly quickly because they
have such a long range of motion and
they control different squares so if you
have the option of having two bishops or
two knights you definitely want choose
two bishops now with that set of bishop
in the night is still very powerful
because they do completely different
things and that's pretty much where
minor pieces with the similarities to
the middle game in there's a lot of
differences with the middle game and in
game and that's what I really want to
focus on today one of the big
differences that you want to take a look
at when you approach the middle game
compared to the end game is how the pawn
structures affect your minor pieces
compared to the endgame if you take a
look at the middle game it's usually
common to use your pawns to block off
your opponent's bishops in this case
black is using his pawns to barricade
this LightSquared Bishop for white so
that white cannot use this Bishop to its
full effect as you can see black has all
its pawns on these light squares and
this light square bishop can't go
anywhere because he's blocked in by all
these pawns in the endgame it's a little
bit different and we're going to take a
look at that here and this endgame as
you can tell you instead don't want to
place your pawns on the same color as
your opponent's Bishop in this case if
you look at it black has his pawns on
light squares
and why it has is pawns on the dark
squares as you can see here white is
able to attack all the pawns from black
but black is unable to attack any of the
pawns from white and this is a key
difference in the middle game you want
to have your pawns on the same color as
your opponent's bishops we're in the
endgame you really like to have your
pawns on the opposite color of your
opponent's Bishop so in this case why
it's going to have a much better game
because he can attack all the pawns from
black but black in turn cannot attack
any of the pawns from white so in this
situation as you can see White has a
much better game because there's nothing
black can really do to attack any of the
pawns you can't really put much pressure
so in this situation this black Bishop
is almost worthless yes he can take away
some squares from our King moving but
this Bishop for white is going to be
much more potent and he can attack all
these different pawns and force black to
make a lot of different moves so this is
one of the key things that you want to
take a look at we're going to take a
look at example of how you can use this
in your in game when you approach
different situations let's go and take a
look at this example it's a pretty
common end game is you'll see both sides
have four pawns both sides have a bishop
on the dark square and both sides have
their Kings centralized you always want
to centralize your King in the endgame
because it becomes a very valuable asset
that you can use he actually is a very
very powerful piece in the endgame but
it's white to move and go and think
about the theme that we just talked
about and think about what do you think
would be the best move for white
let's go and talk about it before I show
you the move but if you can see both
sides have a bishop and they're both on
the dark square and white would really
like his pawns to be on the light
squares and this opponents to be on the
dark squares in the middle game it's a
little bit different as we talked about
but the endgame you don't want to block
your own fish your ball from your pawns
and you want to be able to attack your
opponent's pawn so in this scenario the
best move for white is pawn to a4 and
what this does is it solidifies the
light squares for the pawns from white
White's Bishop is no longer trapped in
by his own pawns and he can attack
freely all the pawns from black black
and turn is only going to be able to
attack his own pawn
he's not going to be able to attack the
pawns from white White's next move if he
wants to can bring his pawn his next
pawn to b3 and there's nothing black can
do a lot of times when I approach an in
game and it's a bishop in game I always
like to look at can I put all my pawns
on a different color within my
opponent's Bishop and if I can I know
that I usually have a winning endgame
there may be a few other factors
depending on where the Kings are where
the pawns are if the pawns are close to
promotion but if they're in the middle
and the Kings are centralized as long as
I know I can put my pawns on a different
color than my opponent's bishop I know
that his bishop is completely taken out
of the game and that's just another
advantage that I can take going into the
endgame so you always want to look at
this when you're approached a bishop in
game is how you evaluate your pawn
structure and how you can use that pawn
structure to help you with your bishops
compared to how you would look at it in
the middle game so let's go and take a
look at a few more things that are
different in the endgame than the middle
game
let's take a look at this example here
and think about which side is better in
this spot and actually why it's better
because he has a bishop but his bishop
is good because there's palms on both
sides of the board and the endgame if
you have pawns on both sides of the
board you prefer a bishop because he can
get to both sides
very quickly a lot of times an in-game
the positions going to be open so you
don't want to just look at open but you
want to look at where the pawns are the
bishop can get to both sides where
although the knight can control very
critical squares it's going to be very
hard for him to get back and forth from
both sides of the board very quickly but
if you look at if we take away these
pawns from the a file black is actually
better off this Knight although we can't
get to both sides of the board he
doesn't need to he can control the
critical scores he needs to on these two
fought on the G and the H file where the
bishop although he can move around the
board freely he's not going to be able
to control the critical squares that the
knight is so if you have pawns on both
sides of the board in the endgame
bishops are going to fare better where
if pawns are on to only one side of the
board Knights are actually going to pair
better so these are a few of the things
some of the differences that you will
see in the in-game from other parts of
the game hopefully you've enjoyed some
of the other videos that are going to be
coming up in the in game strategy and
tactics lessons are going to be great so
if you haven't already please subscribe
thanks for watching I'll see you guys
next video